c'est ça et après il y en a qui sont
désistés on va voir ce qu'on pense à
FIDA et puis j'ai surtout envie de
savoir si elle a déjà rencontré Gérard
pardieu ou si voilà voilà voilà voilà
voilà euh on va revenir sur l'acte
héroïque des vacances c'est celui de
Nathan Nathan 13 ans qui a sauvé sa sœur
et sa mère après un violent accident de
voiture survenu le jour de Noël dans un
dans une forêt de l'erou Nathan et sa
famille sont avec nous ce soir dans un
instant c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait
Nathan ouis excuse-moi tu es cru chez ta
mère toi non mais pardon non mais
j'entends SG j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
un animal dans
les tu fais ça sur vu mon micro était B
non mais pas ton micro est toujours
brangé Gill tu lui
par je m'en vais alors non mais e s'il
te plaît respecte les gens décédés merci
euh allez
regardez 25 décembre dernier Nathan a un
accident de voiture avec sa mère et sa
sœur
le véhicule quitte la chaussée dévale
une pente en tonneau et atterrit tout
près d'un ruisseau Nathan détache sa
sœur coincée à l'arrière et s'occupe
ensuite de sa mère ces gestes de premier
secours Nathan les avait appris quelques
semaines plus tôt lors d'une
intervention à l'école des gestes qui
ont sûement sauvé la vie de sa
mère merci naan merci d'être avec nous
et merci Jessica merci beaucoup vous
êtes la maman et merci François pompier
intervenu sur le lieu de l'accident
merci François merci d'être là alors
Nathan tu es vraiment le héros de de cet
hiver c'est un truc de fou est-ce que tu
peux nous raconter ce qui s'est passé
parce que on va tous se mettre à la
place de de Nathan et et on se dit tous
même nous adulte ici je pense pas qu'on
aurait eu le courage et les gestes que
tu que tu as eu les réflexes que tu as
eu euh ben en fait la voiture elle a
commencé à tomber ouis et du coup ben la
voiture elle a fait deux tonneaux elle
est tombée en bas et ma mère elle a
perdu connaissance et elle avait la tête
dans l'eau et du coup je l'ai sorti et
je l'ai mis sur le côté
et après j'ai détaché ma sœur j'ai sorti
ma sœur après ma mère s'est réveillée
j'ai j'ai sorti ma mère enfin je l'ai
aidé à sortir de la voiture et après
j'ai grimpé le talu en haut je suis
allée au derrière la barrière au bord de
la route et j'ai arrêté quelqu'un pour
leur dire qu'ils appellent les pompiers
incroyable franchement c'est fort il
paraî que tu l'as mise en position de
sécurité par que tuava appris des gestes
des gestes qui sauvent juste TR de de TR
semaines avant c'est ça ouiécole et tu
t'en es souvenu c'était quoi C à l'école
oui et donc tu t'es dit ouais je me'en
rappelle je me souviens voilà j'ai j'ai
tu vois c'est ça la différence entre toi
et moi c'est que toi tu écoute à l'école
moi j'aurais rien pu faire tu vois non
mais Jessica c'est fou quand même oui
ouais ouais c'est c'est c'est c'est vous
êes est-ce que vous vous pensiez qu'il
il était capable de faire ça ben non
enfin je sais pas enfin franchement euh
il il m'en avait parlé 2 semaines avant
qu'à l'école il avait appris les
premiers geste de secours qu'il avait
mis des mannequins tout ça donc il m'en
avait parlé de semaines avant mais bon
euh c'est fou al pas prévoir euh vous
avez vous avez perdu le contrôle de la
voiture c'est ça euh en fait non enfin
je me suis engagée dans un chemin et euh
en reculant en fait j'ai vouu euh
reculer et euh la voit la roue a
commencé à la terre était un peu humide
donc la roue a commencé à à s'effondrer
et et on est on a basculé sur le côté et
j'essayie de raccélérer je suis pas
arrivé et là on s'est vu on s'est vu
tomber dans le vide panique totale quoi
au premier choc j'ai perdu connaissance
alors euh quand vous avez repris
connaissance vous avez entendu votre
fils en fait j'ai perdu connaissance
mais j'entendais ce qui se passait dans
la voiture donc je sentais que j'avallis
de l'eau et et en fait ben j'entendais
mon fils qui me disait maman
réveille-toi maman réveille-toi mais
j'arrivais enfin je pouvais pas me
réveiller et en fait il m'a tiré et j'ai
pu vu qu'il m'a mis sur le côté j'ai pu
recracher l'eau et euh je j'ai commencé
à reprendre mes esprits petit à petit et
et après il m'a guidé pour sortir sur la
toute petite fenêtre arrière de du
véhicule pour pour sortir alors François
vous êtes un des pompiers intervenus sur
le lieu d'accident quand vous êtes
arrivé sur les lieux euh il vous a dit
quoi Nathan vous avez vu Nathan vous
êtes dit alors c'est vrai que la
première réaction qu'on a eu c'est de
c'est la rencontre avec Nathan donc il
nous a de
suite guidé ou c'est quiétait sa maman
et sa petite sœur pour qu'on porte
assistance et qu'on fasse les les gestes
les gestes pour pour récupérer sa petite
sœur et sa maman hein on l'a trouvé très
professionnel si on peut dire euh parce
que on a été surpris euh de ce petit qui
euh qui a su donner donner l'alerte qui
a su avoir les bons gestes et qui nous a
guidé au au mieux parce qu'il faut
savoir que on le dit toujours le les
premiers les premiers acteurs dans un
accident euh c'est le témoin c'est le
secouriste et plus le plus les ils vont
donner des informations exactes et juste
plus les secours vont arriver juste pour
parce que pour nous c'est le temps le
temps
ousexéle castrhe il jamais ce
que pas inroable qu' fait ah tout à fait
tout à faitin c'est pour ça que on
espère que Nathan à l'âge de 16 ans
rentrera dans le rang des pompers
volonta tu en as envie ou pas oui
ah donc j'espère être son tuteur ah bah
Françis obligéanchement non tu en as
envie ou pas franchement c'est serait
ton kif oui ça pourrait faire un travail
oui et ben en tout cas bravo à toi parce
que tu as tu as été incroyable alors je
voulais te faire quelques petits cadeaux
est-ce que tu as une tablette tactile tu
as une tablette tactile pour Noël non je
t'en offre une est-ce que tu as un
smartphone une friteuse
friteuse tu veux une friteuse non mais
est-ce que est-ce que tuas tuas un
smartphone oui moi je t'en offre un
deuxième est-ce que tu as un pack
audioir c'est un truc bien et j'offre ça
aussi François j'aimerais t'offrir aussi
un cadeau parce que je te trouve
formidable et je voudrais dire les
pompiers voilà je suis fou des pompiers
à chaque fois que je vois un pompier je
me dis voilà c'est eux ils font un vrai
métier et franchement vous êtes
incroyable et je voulais te dire
François merci donc j'aimerais t'offrir
aussi des cadeaux pour toi et ta famille
voilà pour d'être venu merci merci V et
vous aussi merci d'êt ven merci merci
vous êtes
formidable merci François merci Jessica
merci Nathan et Nathan juste à l'école
tu as un héros là ou pas à l'école ouais
oui pas mal là pour les meufs et tout
non j'avoue franchement c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal non tu sens qu'il y a un
je sais pas il y a un
engouement un regard d'érê c'est ça
merci en tout cas merci savez qu'il a un
nom prédestiné lui c'est incroyable ou
ou
ouite bien ou'pp
ayuda en espagnol ouah tuas faire
[Applaudissements]
l'ission tu faire l'émission en Espagne
tu vas arrêter de nous faire chier tu
faire l'émission sur la
Costa merci merci François merci
François en tout cas un prénom un nom
prédestiné ayuda ça veut dire laineide
en
espagol Montiel ça veut dire bar-toi en
français allez merci on va revenir euh
sur